attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
être en relation avec un téléopérateur
résidant dans un pays en développement
votre attente oui bonjour bienvenue chez
tric ce que puis-je pour moi mais
qu'est-ce que vous foutiez ça fait vingt
minutes que j'attends oui mais on est
trois points 50 à peine 1 je suis pas
une pieuvre de vous faire payer le
numéro surtaxé
donc ils vous attendent et plus vous
payez alors quel est le problème
mon problème c'est que ma box a lâché du
coup j'ai plus d'internet voilà ou alors
on va vérifier sa hanche en touche qui
capte mal c'est bon ça vient de moi on
est en tunisie en fait c'est à dire que
ça coûte beaucoup moins cher de
délocaliser pour ce genre de service
alors j'ai peut-être une solution très
con est ce que vous avez pensé à
débrancher rebrancher la boxe ça oui
j'ai moins de 45 ans mercy n'ont pas
très bien déjà on n'est pas sur un débit
qui a passé 25 minutes au téléphone pour
rien ça fait longtemps qu'on n'est plus
internet
je vois deux heures deux heures et demie
pourquoi cette question
non pour rien rien fait on vous pose
beaucoup de questions si pour vous faire
croire qu'on va trouver une solution
mais surtout pour gagner du temps
sceptique j'entends là c'est une autre
responsable qui écoutent nos
conversations produit surtout pour
pousser à la vente avait parlé les
problèmes des clients c'est sympa mais
c'est pas ça qui va nous faire bouffer
non plus
oh là là mais je vois que vous avez
lancé une box c'est pour ça que ça
marche pas celle à six mois celle ci
aide à oui mais maintenant faut la
nouvelle
ok d'accord sur la nouvelle je peux la
chope et où ça coûte moins cher le
patron n'a aucune boutique
donc on va vous l'envoyer par la poste
il y en a pour un mois y a pas un
endroit où je peux parler à quelqu'un
physiquement là deux minutes avec tous
les clients qui sont en colère contre
eux nous aurait pété la gueule tous les
jours on n'est pas content non plus à
l'est la bonne journée hier voir
[Musique]